- [Instructor] So we are
asked to drag the point
to 12.5 on the number line, so let's see.
Let's see, this is 12, and 12.5
is halfway between 12 and 13
then say say what is 12.5
rounded to the nearest 10?
Well, what's cool about
this is you can see
on the number line that our
tens are in this blue hash.
So we have 10 and then 20
and we're between 10 and 20
and which one are we closest to?
Which is literally the nearest 10?
Well, you can see we are
closer to 10 than we are to 20
so you would say 10, and this
helps us build an intuition
for what rounding to the
nearest 10 even means
because you might know a rule like,
hey look, you go one place
less than the tens place,
which would be the one's place
and if it's less than five
there you round down to 10.
If it's five or greater
you round up to 20.
But you see why over here,
we are just closer to 10.
Let's do another example here.
So here it says drag the point to 0.136.
So this is 0.13, this is
0.14, so this is 13 hundredths
and this is 14 hundredths, now let's see.
There's one, two, there, four,
five, six, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
So these are, you could think
of it as the ten thousandths
between these two hundredths.
So we want to go 13 hundredths
and then another six thousandths.
So let's see, we go one,
two, three, four, five, six.
Just like that, and then
they say what is this number?
136 thousandths or 0.136 rounded
to the nearest hundredth.
Well, we have our hundredths in blue here,
and which one are we closer to?
Well, we're closer to 14 hundredths, 0.14.
And that's consistent with
what we've seen in other cases
where you look at the thousandths place
and if it's five or greater you round up.
In this case, you would
round up to 14 hundredths.
Let's do a few more examples here.
So let's say that, so they're asking us
which point is at 44.197
on the number line?
So let's see, that's going
to be between 44 and 45,
so it's right over here, 44.197,
so that would be point C.
And then they say, what is 44.197 rounded
to the nearest whole number?
Well, there's a couple of
ways to think about it.
You could just look at the tenths place
and say look, that's less than
five so we round down to 44
or a more intuitive way
of thinking about it
is like look, point C is
the number we care about.
That is 44.197.
What's the closest whole number to it?
Is it closer to 44 or is it closer to 45?
Well, it's clearly closer to 44,
so that's another reason
why 44 makes a lot of sense.
Let's do another example.
Let's say that we want to, so they say,
what is A rounded to
the nearest thousandth?
What is A rounded to
the nearest hundredth?
So A is right over here,
let's get our bearings.
So 0.7, that's seven hundredths.
This is eight hundredths right over here.
And then between them, let's see,
this looks like it's
zero, so you can view this
as 70 thousandths, 71
thousandths, 72 thousandths,
73 thousandths, 74 thousandths, and so on.
So this is between 78
thousands and 79 thousandths.
So if we round to the nearest thousandth
it looks closer, in fact,
it's definitely closer
to 78 thousandths than
it is to 79 thousandths.
So I would say this is
0.078, or 78 thousandths.
That's closer, that's
the nearest thousandth.
What is A rounded to
the nearest hundredth?
Well, what are the hundredths
that it's in-between?
It's in-between seven
hundredths and eight hundredths.
And which one is it closer to?
Well, it's closer to
eight hundredths, 0.08.
So once again, the whole
point of this video
is to appreciate when people say round
to the nearest whole
number, to the nearest 10,
to the nearest thousandth,
to the nearest hundredth,
you can think of it on a
number line and just say,
well, what is the closest hundredth to it?
Or what hundredth is it closest to?
Which thousandth is it
closest to on the number line?